hi there steve here continuing my korean
challenge today
i don't have to cook
because it's our anniversary and we're
going out for dinner
uh
48 years of marriage anyway no reason
not to study korean
and i'm going to show you a little bit
about my routine
uh
on my stepper in that but i wanted to
talk about how
reading and listening has come alive now
i'm a sucker for books wherever i go i
buy books when i was in seoul
recently i bought a number of books for
korea and i have hardly read them
uh this one here is called easy to learn
korean people and hangul
and it's full of totally honest
interesting stories about
fictitious university students having
fun lots of you know joyful pictures
like
you know aren't we whoopity-doo but it's
not real of no interest to me
and they have a tad you know a bunch of
questions which i don't want to do
and of course they have a dictionary
which is a korean to korean dictionary
and i don't like monolingual
dictionaries where i get a bunch of
explanations and words that i don't
understand about a word that i don't
understand
to me
and that's why i'm going to show you
i i tried actually to show you how i
work with my ipad how i can you know if
i find a korean word the blue that i
don't know i can look it up i can attach
the chinese character to it from dumb or
from
naver
it's there the next time
i'm interacting with it i can even some
of these political issues that i come
across i can go to google search in
korean and find out a bunch of
background about that
it's it's so much inter more interactive
than than these boring books and i'm
dealing with
you know stuff that interests me and i
can do it on my iphone i can do it on my
ipad and when i need to be even more
mobile you know i can listen to stuff on
my little
ipod nano so the world of language
learning has become so much more alive
however
i do want to start speaking
and so in fact hannah and i did speak in
korean the other day and we recorded it
and but we hannah wants to edit it and
then maybe see if we can get some
subtitles at any rate she's editing it
right now so it won't be out for another
few days but um
we could do some more of this uh
speaking korean just to see how i show
you how i'm getting along and it's also
a good motivation for me
to realize that every say two or three
days i'm gonna have to talk to hamas so
i better really work on my korean
at any rate that's all and if i can
attach this little video of me working
on my stepper that'll give you a sense
of some of the things that i do to learn
korean in my
um 90 day challenge
and i'm looking forward to dinner bye
for now
so just to show you where i do some of
my
studying
and i got my link
on here
and i got my ipad going
and after i've saved a bunch of words
and all my screen is now full of yellow
words then i get on my stepper here and
i listen and read at the same time
unfortunately there's this noise today
in the chapter so i'm not going to stay
on here for too
but i can go through and follow
and listen to it and as long as i'm
reading and listening i kind of
understand it beyond word i don't know i
looked it up but i've already been
through this text so it's really
important
so i spend 20 minutes on here reading it
means i can get some exercise and at the
same time i can work on my career
but uh
it's just too bad you can't
i don't know if you can hear it
and of course this is what the text
looks like
it's all part of my day
and i will switch to uh
somewhere else i studied during the day
but actually i'm gonna stay on the
supper
and end the video and then i'm gonna do
some other exercises here try and
try and get something in every day every
second day one or another the good thing
to do all your life long stay fit
and also keep studying languages